You can hear it in her voice. I think this woman goes wrong. By the way,
she meets a guy to motel.
I got 11. I stopped making you bag it up.
She got rod dog on the Ramada off the side of route 17.
I think there's a Sonic down the street that she went to bananas.
I think 11 and a half inches inside the body though is passed where AIDS will
get you. Anyway. Think he just hit your stomach acid. At that point,
you've gone. You've gone full abyss. Yeah, you're gone.
You're shooting it right into the pancreas. I'm not,
I'm not a medical professional. He will definitely not damage you.
You will not give you AIDS. You will have terrible reflux. Age is more middle.
That's like, no, this Dick will give you GERD
Because I couldn't attend.
And we weren't there for the marriage of our own hardcore
hardcore. He went straight, hardcore. We went straight. He went legit.
He went legit. Dude. Does she know about your past life?
What'd you have to do with all the gammas.
I told you I'm straight. Now.
I thought we was going to see Frankie Valli this weekend.
You remember when I met you? When I was played as secretary at a move
[inaudible].
Do Oh, he's found his power.
Cory's learned how to open doors.
Corey. I think that Sammy Davis Jr is really talented. A what?
Why don't you take me to ratios?
Why is it always that girl I met you with that office?
All your, all your grandmas, all your office whores your office, porn slots.
Um, big congratulations to Cory. We did.
We did a little something for you here at the bonfire that we always do.
You know what we do? Trans stripper welcome Prairie.
Very progressive. I hope that tripod sturdy.
Cause this thing is coming out flap. I'm going to tell you. We went bought.
We checked bottom first. Oh yeah. And it's heavy. We go bottom top.
So maybe like to go top bottom. I mean thick like a four Loco,
but one that's been half drank, like I say, nights crooked juice. Cory.
Congratulations on your nuptials. We got you. The honorary. Of course,
Jacob loves to take his bike route over to Mrs. Fields.
You can't get married without having a giant cookie Cory and then in, uh,
in Jewish writing on the Mrs. Fields, giant cookie, it says,
of course congrats.
Congrats hard Cory on finding your main Joe that's right?
Yeah. Your main deal, dude. If you started a band,
she would play drums, keyboard plays,
keyboard sort of and sing awkwardly.
[Inaudible].
Corey, you got to break off the first piece. Come on or else it's bad.
Jewish luck. It is we'll break. The first piece of the notch.
We'll look at that piece. Hardcore read, then get two pieces and then cross,
arms and smash it in your own face.
[Inaudible] they got mad.
I know what you're thinking is at a tiny little groom on top of the cookie,
but that was Jacob. Jacob wore a tuxedo to work.
That was Jacob Kerrigan is Jacob. Jacob, sit on topic. Now, Paula,
Paula ripcord. I don't think a love like that could be real
cookie for Greg fields. You sassy.
It's good for a little bit that you do hit a wall with it.
It's the first bite you the best first bite is fixed cigarettes.
The first poll is good. Everything else is everything's going to buy cigarettes,
even though you guys just know that you guys know there's no way.
I mean the crust is the.
Did you ever think you were going to be widely quoted Jacob like regularly
quoted? I would say you are the most quoted person on the bonfire, dude.
I swear to God for sure. For sure. For sure.
100% I and surprisingly whose came into second place real
quick has been the old horny lady. She caught fire.
I instantly.
I love, I love me.
[inaudible].
I think we've watched it once a day. Oh, I watched it at home now.
That's not because my new TV, I can push a button and go kiss my, YouTube.
And it comes on. Are you sure?
Are you sure you wouldn't use his face as toilet paper? I just left the day.
Go in. Yeah, we got to talk to Joseph.
Just wouldn't even use your faces toilet paper. That's a great drop. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh yeah.
Jacob, you are definitely the most people y'all shout at my shows constantly.
Yeah.
Caught me. It still made me laugh when we were doing that,
getting off the elevator and the father, Steve, which is what's his name?
The preacher from across the street. Father, Dave father, Dave go.
You're going to hell father. Dave goes, well, that sounds fun.
You're the one going to hell. You're the one father. Steve that's my father.
You're the one that said Jesus Christ in front of him. So,
so he loves Jesus Christ. That's the way you said it. Why not?
Not the way you say, how did I say it so bad? You could smell the Jewish way.
You said it. What did I say? You went like this. Jesus Christ.
That's not how we talk about the son of God. Why you went like this wrong.
The way I said it, you go, Jesus Christ. I know he is.
I was given like a Jesus Christ, right? Like a nod. No, yes I was no,
because I was talking about something sinful. Then he went, Jesus Christ.
I was trying to get into your heart. No, that's not true. Yes. I was casting.
That's why I was aggressive. I was casting Jesus into the way. Jesus Christ.
[Inaudible] you go? Jesus Christ. His father, his father stayed back.
I've got this one.
[inaudible] pastor here.
Now it is taking the Lord's name and date his.
Now shout not take the name of the Lord, thy God in vain. So there you go, Jay.
Me.
Thank you. It was in vain. What did I say? Jesus Christ.
Because I think I was talking about a hot wouldn't that mean?
Like I was talking about a hot gay God in vain. Be like me going like Amish,
hotter than God. Yeah, you go dude. God's abs suck. Yeah, dude.
I have a much better body than God. A clack he's God, no one even sees him.
Why wouldn't you be fat? Oh dude. I, if I was super in shape,
I would do that in the mirror. As I was posing,
talking about taking the Lord's name in vain. God.
God this body.
I must be. I must be a little devil because God damned this body.
I'm sitting with these abs.
He's like gluttony, lust, pride,
slough, Josie,
Chelsea. There it is.
Sorry. I named my body veins. Sorry. Um, when I get super vascular,
I get super.
Tried to go commit the seven deadlies. Yeah,
I got to go hang and bang and commit some sands.
[inaudible] bust out some sets in the gym.
Get my Dick sucked while I curl.
Is girl more important that there's a guy in the world who wants to do curls
while he gets his Dick sucked into me. You're looking at himself for real,
is that there's a girl who was into blowing a guy while he lifts weights in the
mirror. That girl needs to know that she makes my penis move in my jeans
when I was younger. Me and my girlfriend from right after high school.
Yeah. Swapped with a couple. I've told the story on here before I think.
And Whoa,
how are you doing such progressive at like 18 her friend.
It was very, we were, I kind of take that back because me and my buddy,
I was like, I'd uh, I was probably like a 19. I mean,
that's a pretty crazy situation.
So undeniably a wacky situation and college kid was a friend she worked with,
it was really, it was more of my girlfriend.
She was young when we got together that I think she wanted to experience
something else.
That point she's probably getting that edge more because weirdly enough,
it was kind of brought to me.
She came with the couple in mind that her friend was a girl boyfriend who
was great because he's definitely like, he's older than us.
And he was definitely influencing her.
That's funny that you could watch the vein run to him.
He's just rubbing his chest. And he goes, yeah.
What are Jason and Ellison up to?
It's really actually really funny. So we go, I go, yeah.
She showed me the girl. And I'm like, yeah, she's really cute. I was like,
I'll that chick.
Sure. Guys signing off on that.
The cell is all the woman because the guys are just like, Hey, this girl,
you go. Yeah, what's up. But that's awesome. It's just funny.
No, like what? I didn't know then it's funny. Cause we went to meet him.
I hadn't been out on CD mode. Not far from my place,
but like just a CD motel next to a highway. Think there was a, he had a,
a van with all the trimmings, like the carpet.
It was one of those things. He showed us on the side.
He was a, I mean now, but you know, yeah, no, but yeah.
And he, um.
He goes, how are you doing? But it was just great.
But girlfriend tells me you're hot to try. Yeah. Well my buddy,
Ricky runs this motel. He was all, he was smaller than me.
And he was like a prematurely balding guy, for sure. He was probably going to.
Mid to late twenties. And we were definitely like 19 the best. And uh,
and my chick may have been like 17 or something. You know what I mean?
So like we, uh, we go into this plate and the guy is so funny.
Cause the girl seems she was very all bad at two and into it, his chick. Yeah.
And I'm not even processing that. He's going to my chick. I'm like, sure.
I guess like whatever, I'm gonna get the out of the chicks.
You were so focused on the other girl that you're like,
you didn't even think of the payment. You're like, Hey, what am I? Yeah,
that's fine. Whatever. Yeah.
Cause I'm like, when he, those situations too,
like it's got sort of a dweeb and I wasn't like a cool kid growing up.
But I was like, dude, your girl is a, it's a test of, uh,
whatever. It was comfortable with something with her.
Like I knew how she looked at me. You know what I mean?
She was like ready to somebody else or even ask up. Yeah.
I just know like the way she viewed right into to never like a lack of
confidence in that. So I was like kind of whatever.
And then even when I saw his Dick, ultimately in his story, I was like, yeah,
that's fine. Whatever. But his chicken him where like, you know,
doing like that, we do this, this is great. And, and the guy was giving such the
rap, like the dramatic rap that's put in the vibe of like how we read our thing.
And it was like, cool, chill, couple looking, the whatever. It's the same thing.
Like when people in that world talk like that. Yeah.
And it's funny cause I can't separate. I can't be that.
It's always got to be to me with an air of like kind of silly.
W I don't think silly,
I think grounded in reality because a lot of actions, not the sillies bag yet,
but grounded in reality,
better way to put it grounded in reality where you're kind of like,
we all know what this, what the score is because someone doesn't know the score.
And they go, you know, essentially
what the dude is laying all that on us.
Something about the touch of a hand, but he's doing that.
And let me tell you what I'm doing, what I'm doing. He be skeezy for
[inaudible] Hey, sure. He goes,
you know what I love the most is probably just the energy
transferred, the swirl. But buddy,
this guy was laying that rap out. And what's funny is like, you know,
my girlfriend's looking at him. Like you teach a girl,
he's giving like a college lecture, like, you know, her blank face.
And I'm laughing because I, I get what he's doing. And I'm also just going.
I'm like, yeah, dude, I'll your chick, man. It's like, you stop, stop talking,
man. You made the sale sale is in your office. Let's do the here's, my chick,
whatever. And we started with our own chicks and then it was like,
I don't even remember. Oh, that was the funniest thing. My chick,
I think I'm not saying this for any masculinity purposes.
I think she came on me and her were great.
But I only say that because she didn't, she didn't, well,
it seemed like she did. And then, uh, in my memory it was because she on a dime,
like went from like, almost like, like,
I don't want to know if I want to like do this anymore. Really? And, uh,
she got diving board scared. Well, yeah, I think she came right. But I was not.
Was like, this guy.
But by the way, this is so funny because if I would have come,
I probably would have, you wouldn't want to go to video games immediately.
You want to get out of that situation right away. I'd be like,
is that all the world? How CD it is?
Are we in a place that is silver Knight in or something it's like coming women
don't understand coming from men is like pulling a bag off your head.
And you're like, wow.
[Inaudible] 45 minutes from my house.
I said yes, to a Celine Dion concert.
We got matching tattoos. You go, yeah. Yeah. I'm about to it up. Oh my God.
I flew to Cincinnati.
Buddy, but I didn't, I didn't come. So when she goes, she goes,
I don't know if I want to do this anymore. And I went, uh, I mean, we're here.
I mean, like she ended up doing that.
Here's what's funny was you gave her what you gave Christine at the
drive-through and burger King. We go, how many times have you got a burger?
How many times are you.
Going to be at the dodgy, dodgy roadside motels?
It's going to be a parking lot in three months.
You're going to level this place with these two Oh, deed in it. I mean,
we're here now. And while they're alive, let's get down.
So their hearts are pumping. My hard. Let's rock and roll.
What's funny is now you're talking about a teenager versus this guy,
whatever he is, he's older than me and just more. Yeah, sure.
We can run a car comfortable. And he was like a significantly thinner,
like in better shape guy too. So like, uh, but again, do you think he.
I'd you up similarly to how you eyed him up?
I think he probably wanted to my chair.
I think he wants to any of his girlfriends friends.
Oh, what a skis. He's not really the reality he was doing.
He was doing the character. That's why I don't have a problem with it.
The action as much as like the, the weird, like, you know, that's like,
we're all just spirits floating in it. Like, it was kinda like, you know,
I want to see my GEs on other faces. Yeah.
Yeah. I just can't understand why two bags of cells.
Can't slam
someone about changing sweat with a person,
which I think makes the world a better place on a horse. No,
Amanda kind of want to the description of that.
That's the problem,
I think is the people that get too involved with it like that.
The description of it, like the lifestyle. Yes. The description of it.
Like that makes it to like a, a regular person. No,
but where it's like this identity of what you are, do you know what I'm saying?
Like, and the way you think it's more,
it's more intimate than it should be that situation.
Versus like, you also have just kind of like.
We want to different people. And then it's like, these are different people.
We would get them. I understand the concept of that.
More than like the one being that self.
More self-righteous in like a corny.
When people talk like real corn,
it's as corny as when someone's like something about sharing.
People just makes me want to be closer to other people as opposed to like,
yo dude, your girlfriend's hot as. Can we find you at like tradesies okay.
Do you remember? Do you remember pawns? Tracy's what's funny churches and swim.
I don't know. Double down on one for a little bit. I'm weird. Let's go.
Christina. On one of the cruise ships, a guy came up, he was like, well,
look checking with everybody on board. Are you guys in the lifestyle?
And you're like, I mean, I probably done things that you'll say sure,
but like whatever this gathering is, no, we did actually try to go view it.
Like it was like a public thing. So it wasn't like they were gonna start there.
It was like a mixer thing. Right? Like swingers in the boat.
We tried to watch them like the above.
Yeah. He smoked right into it,
but it looked like it was like nobody was doing it.
It was like, there's people like milling around. No, like even interactions,
a lot of chest rubbing.
I think a lot of people in that world though, it's like being in the lifestyle.
It's like, it's almost like the thing about them as much as like,
you guys are comics. It's like,
that's kind of like the thing that that's their community. I don't know.
I think people, I think people.
That kind of that like, are that it's their identity.
They remind me of people that are too much into coffee.
You're kinda like Jay Lou, as much as the next guy,
I love a cup of Joe first thing in the morning, just like, like the beach.
I'm not going to wear a silk shirt. Cause of it. TJ.
Looks like a guy who would be at lifestyle parties. Yeah. Well it's this Puerto.
Rican shirts look like there was no concert shirt.
Only that even the concentrate is fine. It's a lifestyle party guy right there.
This is Janine. Yes. She is younger than me. He's only three years though.
13 years. Right?
There's a thing where he leads them in with their hands over their head and
spins him around. He goes,
this is Bambi is only three years younger than me.
Times this tasty tree Bambi.
She's like,
You may recognize her from some low level stepmother porn. He goes,
we can do M F FM. We can do, we can do that. My, my, my,
my math, we can do whatever you want. We brought some toys, inbox, brand new.
I'm not.
Going to sell you a whole bunch of boiled stuff.
It was the doodle that pushed me over. Guys. We're not boiling these things.
These are fresh out of the bag, tattoo needles. I'm wiping it down,
giving it, these are biodegradable, but still flush one at a time.
Okay. I get Ruby sanitary.
PRL PRL PRL okay. Now.
All right. I guess we get down to business. Let's get all right. Well,
let's go. Let's switch to smash in let's. As I say, I'll run to the middle.
I go see who ends up in who? Diane
dude. I know. Even with, uh, what'd he say,
you want to butt heads first to talk about awkward starter. I know,
even in our thing, we just do, we do it this weekend. I'm an awkward Stata, Dan.
So an awkward Stata. How to get a swingers party going,
whoever would get something like that going is a champ. How difficult it is.
It's like a good MC. Me and Christina, just a girl.
Even a girl we've hooked up with before. Yeah.
Every time it was still a little bit of like, so now is it a, should we,
I don't know. Now you got to have a go. You got to have a good MC.
Someone's got to lead. Yeah. And I'm saying like a swingers party.
If someone's got a really come out and that's why those date Darlene starts
sucking him. Dude.
[Inaudible].
Darlene. Suck them decks.
That's why those David that's why David Koresh and all those guys co-leaders
always eventually end up having group sex and other people's wives.
People love clap. they love clap. they love speaking in tongues. No,
but David Koresh, all those co-leaders do. They're like charismatic as.
So they get you to believe in their. And then they're like,
what's your wife up tail. Yeah. She's hot.
She should give her her womb to the lamb is should I put some of my spirit
inside of her? He goes, she's probably now you probably don't want that for her.
Do you think she's going to be a good vessel for our savior? Now, you know what
their responsibilities,
and I'm asking you for a loss and I know I've done a lot for you.
That's what you'll say, but why did that deserve? This is.
This is a above and beyond because you know what? When we hadn't signed,
finish up this game.
We'll talk about if Rachel wants security, do the idea that.
I'll tell him of a cult. There might be games of Madden going, Oh my God.
Go forward on down and get it. I swear to God, I'm a break. This car. Is it?
Oh, we got to go pray to the East and uh, sharpen Kirby, swords.
Of Jonathan
crushed of Jonathan. How dare you?
Yeah, it was the bonfire commissions radio series. 695.
I don't know if we said that in the beginning of the show.
We just had too much fun up top. We just had big.
Cookies. I'm big joker sin. That's Dan Soder and then we got big sexy guests.
Yeah. Uh, of course you can catch him at uncle Vinny's in New Jersey,
September 27th and 28th comics, Mohegan sun,
October 3rd through the fifth and the punchline of Sacramento.
He's all over October 10th through the 12th. It's Chris
[inaudible] Chris de comedy.com.
For tickets and all that stuff. Good to see you. History. High yields.
Vinny's has already sold out. Cause you know what I mean?
For real though, I got my chain out guy.
If you want to tickets for that, you didn't get him.
Suck. My brother. Get out of here.
My promo code for all my upcoming shows is guy, guy. When I got my chance.
You go typing guy, get 20% off right at the door. Yeah.
Type in Trump, 2020, get 50% off.
Chrissy. Do you go to his Instagram right now? Chris is Stefano.
[inaudible] Stefano. He a Christy comedy, Christy comedy. That's what,
Christine's all comedy Christy on the handles.
I've known Chris over 10 years and he has a story.
Great story about what happened to him on nine 11 with his mom and his, uh,
and then he got expelled from high school and I was dad got him back into high
school and he'd always told me the story. Yeah. It's always such a great story.
We finally did it on stage at the village underground where you half in the bag
where you.
Yeah, I came in a little hot and it was on nine 11 and the comedians,
the two guys before me, Greg comics. Great. Oh, you know,
I'm sure friends of the show, but they just,
if people were kind of eating it because you know,
it was somber in there and it was like nine 11. It was getting late.
So I just came out. I was like, I'm just going to go in.
And Liz had offered me hummus in the back of the room and I was just like, nah,
today that's the enemy's food tonight.
And then I just went on stage and said that and it got a laugh. And I was like,
okay, I can have license now to just tell this story.
Like I'm sitting on my stoop in Brooklyn and it's great.
You know, the great thing about the underground.
They have that unbelievable camera where you can just take a clip.
So Chris took a clip, put it up as an scream, go watch HGTV. It's hilarious.
I watched, you're taking a dump and you close my. At least eight times
you break off the stream. You go.
Chris, anybody in the lifestyle ever ask you to bang their wife while you watch?
No,
but I'm talking to this girl on Instagram and all she's doing is she's like all
about swingers and all that stuff. And she just sends me. I mean,
almost every day, multiple times a day,
she sends me DMS of come like other guys come on her. And I'm like,
I don't like this at all.
Hi Dan. Soder I do like that photos.
Do you want to be looking for in this situation?
I would take a picture of one man's herbage is another man's treasure.
It's her with come with other guys hits.
Her open with, come on it. That's.
Your stuff with these things. You're open. I'm.
This girl's built for a long, you looking for a long distance commitment too.
Kara. But I was just like, yeah. I mean, look at this. She just,
it's just other guys, you know? Wow. You can't see this one.
Are you impressed with the com? Are you impressed with the amount of come? Well,
hold on. He's got a thick old mushroom though.
I don't know if he caught there's one where he,
she takes a shot and sends it to me. She just messaged me right now.
Cereal.
Corey, Corey, you want to check the lighting on his video over here?
You want to know if this is a lot of trouble for that, right? It's weird.
The girl. No, he's he's done lighting for porn before. So where it makes him
[inaudible].
No, she taught, wait, let me show you the one. Just because I just.
Want her it's just her with like a Dick and like the way she looked at it,
it looked like a sound check. She was like, Whoa,
that's a big J pick show. Big J that pick what we want. Uh,
here's one which is coming our. This girl's great people at home.
Have no idea what's happening.
Chrissy D showing me pictures of this woman that he's, DM-ing, uh,
these sex pics of other guys on a radio show.
But I don't want to put it on the camera to show like this. Oh, fantastic.
You're sending me this party pictures. And it's like, it's a script.
Definitely. Swingers parties, definitely in the lifestyle.
Cause she was getting that picture of her blowing that dude.
She was definitely getting bang for behind. She was
my lawyer saw the same magic. I Chris.
I don't believe it.
What do you mean? You got to show Jacob.
[inaudible] a good cake. I haven't had a bite. Oh, it's up? Well,
we wanted to talk about there and the, uh, she's just, I mean,
this girl is Vegas fun boomerang.
Yeah. And she'll like, just be open with me. She'll be like, Oh yeah,
I'm going to get right now. What are you doing? I'm like,
I'm taking my daughter to karate.
I mean, Chrissy V is a cocksman. Yeah. What happened?
What happened in Vegas was, uh, I was, I was fighting a war on two fronts.
I was fighting. I had a, there was Asian girls and then there was Korean,
Korean, Korean women. And then there were, and then there were the allies,
there was a French girl. There was a two French women. And um, yeah, I,
um,
it was one of those things where at one point they were all in the pool together
and uh, I didn't know what to do. Cause they were both drunk,
like sizing each other up. I wound up hooking up with the French girl.
But did you have French girl know.
About the Korean girl.
Eventually what was happening and she didn't care. She didn't give a.
What were we going back to? My hotel. I'm just like you made that high choice.
Yeah. Did you talk like that? I don't know.
Me and Dan went a full-blown car ride home. We weren't a full-blown.
We said we were bond firing live in the back seat.
Trying to make the pretty girl laugh. We were both just being two dancing apes.
So Chris can go back and just her stuff.
So Chris saw us go full James, going a bit less funny in that car ride January,
I would work. Yeah. We both went full insecure. Eighth graders were like,
this is how we live here. Look at me. You want us to be dude?
I can clap the fast I can climb the fastest
cigarette button.
You think that cigarette button I can fall downstairs and it doesn't hurt.
I can take a punch. I can take Dan's hardest. Punch, punch.
Can't hurt me it off. Then punch my belly. I don't care. I go home. I go, I go,
pretty lady. Watch her jump off the roof. I landed.
I could have been snoring in the back. He was still getting late. I dunno,
watching these two idiots and were like, yeah, you want to see?
I can snap faster than you. I can step so much faster than you. Yeah,
the do we were saying that you're in the back.
Like these are my two Dick head friends. This is dummy and dummy. She goes,
I mean, panties off to mile markers. They got Chris is like
[inaudible]. Oh, it looks, I got to go downstairs.
I'm just kidding. I got my nose. Yeah.
It was my thumb. Whoa. It's off. Anyways. I grew up in Colorado.
Are you from that? Name's pretty cool. Is that of an origin story?
Yeah. Do you watch eczema? Like what the. Yeah, dude.
That was funny. Watching Chris, as we talked about previous on the show,
when we got back from Vegas,
Chris walking into the four Korean girls where he had the four drinks,
we were talking about how you did the, you can't enter a pool without me.
No. He says the thing. When you,
when you have people's attention before you're close enough to really talk and
you got to like do a thing. And I was trying to get still detection.
I think I was the only one looking at you,
but you had four drinks walking over to these girls just to, to perfect,
like hot Asian girls on like rafts with their asses up.
And you came over and you were just making the noise. You were like.
There's that things.
You have to do something while you're coming into the group.
And we started doing it and we were all doing it like a half hour ago there. Ah.
[Inaudible].
Did those girls care about you leaving with the French girl? No.
Because they wanted the Asian girl flew to New York last week.
Anyway. So she goes, I respect your honor.
Little told me the truth. You're going to get. Well,
they were all leaving that night. Right? They were.
Leaving. I didn't have a lot of.
Talking to chicks and my shirt off.
Isn't my biggest game down there on the list. He knows me. I was doing.
A little shot.
I was always doing a shark float up to the latest where it was his neck out of
the water. You know what I was going.
Because my shirt on is right behind home surgery.
Verse eight, Paul versus he got in the pool with a Yankee hat on and his chain.
I was like, you're such a cool Jean, Shane and cigar.
It definitely hung out on the side of the pool where he could put both of his
arms up. So you could show off your dad chest. And he goes, he the aid.
As if annoys gods the shape of muscular chest. Yeah.
He goes, I pick up a four year old, at least three times a day. $8. Yeah.
It was impressive. It was also funny watching all the comics,
because Chrissy D brought in all the hot girls.
W Dan jumped in that pool really for the group, I would say did a,
did a solid for the group of like, cause they, we had some, uh,
there's coyotes in the group. Yeah. You had the roses, uh.
His hyena laugh from the pool where she goes, who's that? I go,
just stay down and they just don't bring up.
Don't bring up mod rock or anything in the late eighties.
Like do your girls a heavy tinted friend and,
and very early in the game just goes like, ah, that's so crazy.
Where's your boyfriend is your boyfriend. You that TV show.
It was like something that had nothing to do with anything.
We all knew that the smoking hot one was go with you.
So then everyone else was starting to smell around the big one that was.
I actually observed. This was what was fun about it. I just called the anthro.
I observed this from like.
Outside the circle. Yes. And so I just came in brazen and I was like,
what's your boy.
I tech. Cause I was unsure to like bring these girls.
Cause I had the groups of girls and we're all at the pool and we were there.
So it was like, I texted Dan at 2:05 PM and I said,
should I invite chicks to the pool? Or you think it's just not cool?
And he at two Oh six, he writes capsule like, yes, you should please. God. Yes.
Oh, sorry. I wasn't keeping you left.
[inaudible] going to do. And he was like, wait, Dan,
I want to say what's so funny about the line, whatever the, whatever the line.
You said about it was just like, if it was a thing that made sense,
it made no sense. You were like, exactly. She goes a bunch,
a bunch of comedians. And you were like your boyfriend,
like comedy made no sense.
Yeah. Yeah. And she was in the pool and Jay's right.
Like we were sitting there and she's like, yeah,
she's ever going to go to like a lazy river is going to be a girls' day.
And I was like, you're hanging out with a bunch of comedians,
bunch of goofballs in my rise. Your boyfriend worried about that.
Yeah. Thinking about all that. She was like, she goes, it's fine. It.
Doesn't really care. You saw the circle go.
Everyone, relax. They're almost like owl. I walked over to Dan and I go.
You can do that grenade out there for the group. And then just cut the land.
There's no way to stop someone when you're seeing them do it.
And when I see the Rosa, the time-lapse photography of the clock,
changing times of the rows of going in and I watched them do this,
my whole friendship with him when he lived with me, especially it's like, joke,
can we leave? I'm going to leave in like an hour. And then in an hour he's like,
Oh, just give me another half hour. I'm always like, no,
you don't understand saving that saving the time. As much as it's like, no,
you don't understand that I'm falling in love.
We know everything about each other. Everything is the same.
And then you're like, she's got a boyfriend, dude.
I think he's like even coming out at some point later or something.
I just think mother. He did that ad in Vegas.
That girl was with her for, I mean, that was a good hour of genuine time.
And he was like, you liked that beat. I love that.
[inaudible] I loved how he was explaining. He was like, yeah, I'm on keto now.
But he still has. Don't say that yet. You just started a week ago.
Don't say results
on KIDO. Must've just sit down.
And his towel wrapped around his waist and sitting on that thing. I was like,
if I was sitting in that thing tank top,
at least I'll never forget my t-shirt on. Right. When I got out of the pool,
of course on the side in my t-shirt I would leave it on the side of the pool.
If I didn't think it would get wet, that'd be way worse. Yeah. Oh yeah.
But when I told him what I did tell him, I go, yeah, dude, I found out Jay goes,
soda, ripped it open in the pool.
He rip that bandaid off in the pool and he's like,
he put it so much time until it. Yeah. It,
he was even talking to the girl that I was with. But like,
we were already like sexting for like weeks. He was like,
what's up with that chick? And I just showed pictures on my phone.
I was like that. And then he was like, Oh, that's cool. Oh,
she really loves zap.
Funny fashion. It wouldn't be funny to just start gaffers.
It's a union break right now. Uh, we look like this is transpo
pipe fitters that we have,
but maybe you stopped. We can unload your stuff.
You guys look like our friends that call us gay for having a radio show.
We could do talk
[inaudible] was work on the renown. Jerry OSHA
on bonfire. We went deep on Jerry. Oh,
that's how I think it's in every room like this. We went to go check.
We went to go pick a hot sheet on the
[inaudible]. It's like someone picking up. You're like, Oh,
I know that girl. She's a real horror.
And then she goes over in French kiss is your best friend.
[inaudible] nothing wrong with that.
I've been trying to get into his shoulders and sliders.
I was just telling these guys you're looking at driver's eyes and you see the
kid from stand by me the minute you it.
It makes you look like you're probably walking out of frame.
You massage man of questionable sexuality. Absolutely.
Uh,
the only thing worse than you're recognized for being a fee is when you think
you are. And he doesn't know he was right there at solving the reflection.
He already took two pictures. So take that Jay
[inaudible]. He goes, I'm sorry. Now we're filming something.
You to make all the cameras at home. I go, no, I can't kiss your baby.
I'm sorry. It shows fine, but it's just a show. I
just stop the conversation. What's that? What's called Giamatti.
Like just a regular guy.
[inaudible] it was pants with both legs at the same time. I don't know.
It's just a gifted guy that I I'm honored to call my friend.
[inaudible] celebrity boxing. Chris Cuomo here this month.
That ain't hi, big fan.
Oh, hi. Didn't see you come in there. I'm Dan Soder I'm big joke person.
We're from the bonfire on comedy central radio, Sirius XM 95.
Make sure you watch our videos. Every Thursday on comedy central YouTube,
fresh, exclusive visual titillating.